[Music]
adele is setting off engagement rumors
after wearing a massive ring on that
finger at the brit awards tuesday night
[Music]
that's the 33 year old singer looking
stunning in an armani black v-neck dress
with a sheer neckline at the annual
ceremony but it's the sparkler on her
left hand stealing all the attention
that right there is a lorraine schwartz
diamond ring which is definitely hard to
miss the pear-shaped sparkler was front
and center as adele posed for photos on
the red carpet
and even with an outfit change the
grammy winner kept the piece of jewelry
on during her performance of i drink
wine on stage
[Music]
adele continued wearing it while
accepting her many awards including best
album very proud of myself for sticking
to my guns and putting out an album that
was about something so personal to me
because not many people do stuff like
that anymore
now the engagement speculation comes
just months after adele confirmed her
relationship with sports agent rich paul
during her sit-down interview with oprah
in november and let's not forget many
fans think her latest single oh my god
is about her man
[Music]
fast forward to january and the
songstress unexpectedly postponed her
las vegas residency show hi um um listen
i'm so sorry but um
my show ain't ready and
i can't give you what i have right now
um
and i'm gutted
and rumors started swirling that adele's
personal life may have had something to
do with it but leave it to the rolling
in the deep singer to shut down that
idea in a cheeky way i'm a control freak
check out the pic she posted on
instagram last week to reveal her
performance at the brit awards in the
caption she seemingly addresses the
rumors that her relationship was on the
rocks simply writing oh and rich sends
his love
e.t has reached out to both adele and
rich for comment
personal life aside the english
entertainer has a lot to celebrate i'm
very very humbled out of adele's four
nominations at the brits she walked away
with three wins taking home trophies for
song of the year for easy on me artist
of the year and album of the year for
30. obviously i thank everyone i work
with like the labels and stuff but i'd
like to dedicate this award to my son
[Applause]
[Music]
you